[Musique]
l'association santé environnement dans
sans dérogation est dans son caddie ce
matin avec nous avec sarah privat la
trésorière de cette association bonjour
aux gens vous êtes une demi douzaine
d'associations à ne pas être contente du
tout huit associations avoir exprimé
cette colère directement au président de
la république en co signant une lettre
sur les lmr de chlordécone les limites
maximales de résidus notamment dans la
viande bovine
sarah privat des lmr a baissé mais que
vous considérez quand même comme étant
toujours un véritable scandale pourquoi
alors un véritable scandale dans la
mesure où depuis le début de cette
histoire de chlordécone
on a vu différentes situations du déni
de l'acceptation et maintenant on est
dans des controverses et donc la lmr
aujourd'hui elle n'est pas acceptable
nous attendons le zéro chlordécone
limite maximale résiduelles pour nous
inacceptable
elle varie elle a varié en 14 ans
quatre fois elle a augmenté puis
diminuer et augmentent et diminuent et
donc c'est un petit peu le yoyo de la
lme aujourd'hui c'est ce qui vous fait
dire que c'est du grand n'importe quoi
pour vous ah oui c'est plus que du grand
n'importe quoi en terme de gestion d'un
dossier aussi sensible que la
chlordécone
on se rappelle en 2007 il y avait la
ministre madame bachelot qui avait déjà
diminué les taux de chlordécone en lmp1
pardon donc de la chlordécone
ça a été ensuite comme je vous disais
augmenté en 2017 et puis à nouveau rue
diminué ceci dit ce n'est pas possible
de continuer sur cette lancée
parce que nous savons très bien que la
chlordécone ce n'est pas la dose qui
fait le poison est là j'ai aussi bien à
faible qu'à faible dose cas forte de ce
sont les cumuls surtout qu'ils sont très
dangereux pour l'organisme
tout à fait ce sont les cumule donc
c'est un perturbateur endocrinien
on oublie souvent mais si on fait un
parallèle avec le bisphénol a le
bisphénol a
il a été retiré sur le marché dès 2010
et donc il a les mêmes effets est ce
cependant le bisphénol à lui vous allez
l'éliminer en 24 heures dans vos urines
mais la chlordécone s accumulent et il
vous faudra quatre à cinq années pour
éliminer cette molécule dans votre
organisme
donc c'est vraiment
un problème pour nous aujourd'hui de
santé publique il faut protéger la
population martiniquaise il faut
rassurer le consommateur peau dit est
selon vous à puisque vous êtes vous est
adressée directement au président de la
république on n'en prend pas du tout ce
chemin ah non on n'en prend pas le
chemin
comment voulez aujourd'hui que ça soit
crédit des lmr qui fluctuent taux élevés
sur sur quoi ça repasse aujourd'hui la
lmr nous pouvons nous poser la question
mais chaque est sûre que vous poser
directement emmanuel macron tout à fait
elle repose sur quoi vous allez mais
aujourd'hui vous avez on nous parle tout
le temps d'étude mais de la même façon
qu est ce qui nous permet de dire
aujourd'hui
car telle dose vous en mangez
régulièrement et vous êtes protégé nez
c'est faux d'ailleurs c'est faux mais en
fait ça à privas la question c'est est
ce qu'on peut faire du ziro chlordécone
aujourd'hui du zéro pesticide dans tout
ce que nous mangeons quel que soit
l'endroit où nous achetons nos aliments
alors oui nous pouvons
c'est c'est pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment là on a démontré plusieurs fois
donc je vais prendre le cas nous de
notre association santé environnement
sans dérogation nous avons fait le tour
de la martinique sans pesticides
nous allons à la rencontre des
agricultures on vous dit qu'il ya 40%
des terres qui sont contaminés et d
autres terres il faudrait des exploités
dans chaque commune apparemment il y
aurait des terres en friche
il faut les exploiter ce sera votre
proposition alors y'a pas que ça
notamment pour ce conte de la
chlordécone aux agriculteurs compte de
la chlordécone
il pourrait très bien faire du hors sol
il ya différents types de cultures
d'accord donc déjà on propose et ce
serait même pas nous de proposer j'ai
envie de dire aujourd'hui on est bien
conscient de l'enjeu
économie qui a derrière tout cela et
pourquoi vous pouvez pas être force de
proposition justement ce sont des
associations comme les votes qui sont
qui s'empare d'une problématique et qui
interroge tout le monde c'est vous qui
pouvez être force de propositions des
politiques vous savez sont dans leur
bulle mais est ce que est ce qu'on est
ce que nous sommes entendus parce que
des propositions
les propositions en débat national
justement les proposition était faite et
refaite je vous rappelle que l'année
passée à peu près à la même date il ya
eu le lyannaj pour dépolluer matinik et
qui a eu un forum social avec plus de
cinquante propositions rappelez vous où
on demandait le zéro chlordécone zéro
pesticide
il ya eu 500 personnes dans la rue quand
même et jusqu'à présent on attend
toujours on nous parle encore de lmr de
limites maximales résiduelles en vous il
faut comprendre qu'on vous dit vous
pouvez toujours manger un petit peu de
chlordécone
c'est hallucinant qu'on nous dit ça
aujourd'hui nous pouvons encore
consommer de la chlordécone même à
petite dose leur sert privat avec les
autres associations vous êtes donc
adressé la semaine dernière au président
de la république j'imagine qu'au moment
nous parlons vous n'avez pas encore de
réponse mais vous venez de le dire et
c'est très important vous fait vous êtes
force de proposition à qui avez vous
adressé ses propositions par exemple
celle de l'an dernier est ce que vous
avez eu des retours alors les
propositions de l'an dernier on était
adressée au préfet de la martinique
donc les toits donc l'état d'accord nous
avons une petite réponse succinte cette
réponse est oui ce qui tenait sur une
page à vrai dire
et en réponse à cela non pour dire vrai
en réponse à cela il faut dire que
l'état organisé un colloque en reprenant
exactement les thématiques du lyannaj
donc ils ont fait de l'agriculture la
santé et puis la pêche
nous on avait quatre champs
on avait l'agriculture la pêche la santé
oms avait rajouté le petit côté
réparation donc ils ont refait à peu
près la même forme
en fait si vous voulez et ils ont crié
donc il y avait une rencontre de
professionnels et après il y avait une
rencontre pour lord hutton et il ya eu
évidemment les plan chlordécone lors
finalement l'état bouge alors non non
non non non non et dubitatif je me suis
tu as if parce que c'est très bien que
vous parlez des idées plan chlordécone
ils ont permis de connaître si vous
voulez la molécule en elle-même
ils ont étudié beaucoup la molécule mais
il faut vraiment se poser la question
par a par exemple les lmr
sur quoi repose sur la vtr sur la valeur
toxicologique de référence qui a été
prise par rapport à l'incident caillons
virginie dans l'usiné hopewell d'accord
ils ont prié un taux 0,25 s'était levé
tr et en analysant la consommation des
martiniquais se sont dit bon on va
mettre la lmr mais déjà là c'est déjà 10
et c'est vrai que c'est assez complexe
mais c'est déjà biaisé et les plantes on
déconne il ya eu beaucoup de
connaissances autour de la molécule mais
sur le terrain quelles sont les actions
concrètes pour moi un projet de santé
publique et pour les associations en
place ces actions réaction c'est comment
arriver à 1,0 chlordécone pocl pour
protéger la population et ma gueule
macro qui va vous répondre
ce sont les politiques locales et
politique mise sur pied avec les élus
martiniquais qui devraient être
sensibilisés par cette problématique
beaucoup plus facilement mais écoutez je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous nous
les avons aussi sollicité
nous attendons toujours l'an dernier ils
ont été sollicités
on a fait des réunions la maison des
syndicats donc ça c'était pour le label
du parc naturel régional
le label y suit il suit quelle
manifestation il suit le il fait suite
au forum social à la mobilisation
citoyenne quand même de la faire il faut
que vous bouger davantage
il faut que vous parlez plus fort plus
haut plus fort plus haut il faut oui
sûrement mais il faut aussi que l'état
prenne ses responsabilités sur ce que
vous avez une exigence même prix va vous
avez une exigence est que vous demander
dans un délai rapide
c'est à dire au 1er janvier et janvier
2020 c'est à dire tout de suite là que
les produits offerts à la consommation
des martiniquais soit exempt de tout
pesticide est ce que vous pensez que en
en un peu plus d'un an et demi on puisse
faire quelque chose massive et haletant
ça fait un an et demi
je vous réponds aujourd'hui ça fait 14
ans les premières éléments d'accord donc
la chlordécone a eu des dérogations 93
les premiers élèves mais je crois que
c'était 2007 du min
oui c'est ça 2006 2007 aujourd'hui ça
fait 14 ans donc quand on dit il faut
attendre
non on attend plus puisque comme vous
avez pu le constater il ya un yoyo sur
les deux ça repose et je reviens là
dessus j'insiste il faut que tout le
monde comprenne bien ça repose sur quoi
la limite maximale résidus est tantôt 50
microgrammes tantôt 200 microgrammes
pour le même type d'aliment donc ça
repose sur quoi est ce qu'on va
continuer dans cette voie vous propose
de vous proposer quand même qu on
réquisitionne les terres en friche
sampler décolleront plus rapidement
identifie compris dans les terres du
domaine de l'état
alors c'est ce qui a été proposé oui oui
c'est faisable sa bonne question
il faudra voir c'est aux instances
avaient c'est aux essences donc on a
proposé nous ont fait des propositions
maintenant c'était pareil pour le forum
social on n'arrête pas de faire des
propositions mais il faut regarder
qu'est ce qu'elle est a fait la vraie
question c'est ça c'est pas nous qu'est
ce qu'on propose
voilà on essaie justement de ne pas
rester dans une certaine fatalité de
proposer des choses mais qu'est ce que
l'état fait en vérité donc tout repose
sur l'état pour vous alors touré poste
où repose sur l'état et sur les actions
effectivement citoyenne mais on est si
vous voulez il y a on manque de moyens
financiers
c'est une réalité de moyens humains
aussi il ya des agriculteurs qui font un
bon travail qui fonctionne sans
pesticides et sans corde et comme on met
l'accent sur ces agriculteurs là mais on
ne nous aurions eu plus d'argent je vous
assure que sûrement le travail aurait
été plus concluants merci d'avoir été ce
matin avec nous'' a rappelé yvan
rappelle que d'être la trésorière de
l'association santé environnement sans
dérogation dit-il dans son caddie bonne
journée bonne journée
[Musique]